[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor hi
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
in 2015 david hole was prospecting for
gold in mary borough regional park near
melbourne australia
as he swept over the ground with his
metal detector it suddenly began to
scream
there within some yellow clay he
discovered a very heavy reddish brown
rock
convinced the rock must contain a large
vein of gold he took it home and tried
everything he could to open the rock
after all maryborough is the region of
australia where someone once found the
largest gold nugget it was called the
welcome stranger that was a
173 pound gold nugget back in 1869 so
david was very optimistic
to break the red rock he tried a rock
saw that didn't work he tried an angle
grinder that did nothing he tried a
sharp drill nothing even dousing the
thing in acid
however not even a sledgehammer could
make the slightest crack
finally the rock sat around but in 2021
david brought his mystery rock to the
melbourne museum where geologist henry
dermot told him the 37 pound rock
contained no gold
that's because it was actually a very
rare and very hard iron nickel alloy
meteorite
only the second one that he had seen
come to the museum in 37 years in many
way making this more valuable than gold
they were finally able to cut a sample
of the stone with a diamond saw and
confirm that it was a rock that came
from space
you know pastor ross uh
it tells us in the bible that sometimes
there are rocks that come from space but
that's right pastor doug and of course
we're talking about meteor and there's
some wonderful stories fascinating
stories about meteos that have struck
the earth and i remember reading one i
think it was an amazing fact she did
pass today about a meteor a lot a lot
smaller than this one that that came
through a guy's roof and
a lander on his couch right next to him
i forget the details but it was quite an
incredible story but here you have a
rock that came from space and uh they
didn't quite understand its value or
didn't know where it came from and for a
while it was sort of set aside until it
was taken to the museum and they were
able to do further explorations well of
course that reminds us of what the bible
says about a rock that was set aside
and it was a stumbling rock the bible
refers to but it was a rock of immense
value
that's right you can read in psalm 118
verse 22 it tells us the stone that the
builders rejected has become the chief
cornerstone
and matter of fact it's referred to
about seven or eight times in the bible
that one verse in psalm 118
jesus says in matthew 21 he said to them
have you not read in the scriptures the
stone that the builders rejected has
become the chief cornerstone this was
the lord's doing and it's marvelous in
our eyes now jesus when he quotes this
it's referring to a story in the bible
when
solomon was building the temple
and all the stones were cut at a quarry
separately
and they were you know precisely
measured and then they were brought to
the building site that was a different
location
and the cornerstone because part of it
sat on the bedrock and it was exposed to
a downhill slope
it was an odd shape it was square on
some edges but it was matching up the
rock bed on the other edge and they set
it right in the middle of the building
site hoping that they'd recognize this
was a the whole building was going to be
set by this if you do mason work you
know that your first stone in your first
row
of bricks it has to be straight or
everything else is crooked
well they kept stumbling over it and
tripping over and they finally rolled it
down the hill into the kidron valley
and then when they kept trying to find
the right stone to fit the corner they
realized they had taken the stone that
had been sent from the quarry and rolled
it down the hill and they brought it
back up and it fit perfectly and this
became an allegory of what the jewish
nation did when their messiah came they
they didn't realize the stone that had
been prepared to save the world
that they had
tripped over it they stumbled over it
and
that stone is christ the bible tells us
that we are to build on the cornerstone
of jesus and his teachings
christ said these words of mine they are
the rock upon which we build wise man
builds on that rock
and even in the book of daniel
christ is compared to a stone because
it's that stone that comes from the
heaven like a meteorite
that pulverizes all the pagan religions
of the world and it grows into a great
mountain
several prophecies that talk about these
bible
meteors or stones that's right matter of
fact there's a prophecy in revelation
pastor doug that talks about the falling
of the stars that's one of the signs
also of the coming of christ but the
rock that you read about in the bible i
was just thinking as you're talking
about the rock representing jesus we
also find paul referring to the rock
from which water came during the
wilderness wandering of israel as being
a type of christ that's right another so
christ is the rock that brings forth
living water well friends we have a free
offer we want to make available to
anyone who is watching it's it's an
offer that we don't often give because
it's
it's actually one of our best-selling
magazines and it's about daniel and
revelation both of these prophetic books
are looked at in this free offer we'll
be happy to send this to anyone who
calls and asks in north america the
number for that is simply 800 8356
and you can ask for offer number 604
again it's the daniel and revelation
magazine that's 800-835-6747
and ask for free offer 604 we'll be
happy to send it to anyone here in north
america past that i'm talking about
north america we have people who are
listening to us not only in north
america but through the internet around
the world sometimes we get people who
call as far away as australia and africa
and so friends if you didn't know not
only can you hear us on on the radio but
you can also watch what's happening here
in the studio on uh
facebook doug batchelor facebook page
amazing facts facebook page and we're
also on youtube as well as amazing facts
tv so this is a good time if you'd like
to participate and see what's happening
here in the studio
you can uh go to one of those links
and if you have a bible question our
phone line here to the store to the
studio is
800-463-7297 that's 800-463-7297
and before we go to the phone lines
let's start with prayer
dear father once again we are grateful
that we have this time here at the
beginning of a new week to open up your
word and study together and father we
ask for your spirit's guidance to lead
us into a clear understanding of the
bible and also be with those who are
listening wherever they might be in
jesus name amen amen
well we really go to the phone lines and
we have our first call of this evening
is glenn listening from ohio glenn
you're on bible answers live
as we approach the end of this age in
the book of revelation the prophecies
there begin to showing themselves in
fulfilling
there's one set of
sevens that i know nothing about it i
don't know if anybody knows anything
about it i had
a curiosity of where the people stand on
the seven thunders of revelation 10.
well you know it says right there and
you read about this in revelation 10
verse 3 and verse 4 and he cried with a
loud voice when uh as one of lion roars
and when he cried out the seven thunders
uttered their voices
now when the seven thunders uttered
their voices i was about to write but i
heard a voice from heaven saying to me
seal up the things which the seven
thunders uttered and do not write them
so this was something that at least for
john he was told that it was to be
sealed or
not revealed now i think there's even in
the
book of daniel talks about seal up the
book until the time of the end but at
the time of the end it would be unsealed
so there's been a lot of uh speculation
about what these seven thunders were
yeah you know the bible doesn't tell us
for sure what they are but what is
interesting is that daniel would receive
this envision only to
have a message from heaven the voice
from heaven say seal this up and we
assume that's the voice of god saying
don't write this down so why would god
reveal something to the prophet and then
say oh now don't write that down unless
it there's something revealed that's not
perceived at first and if you look at
all of revelation chapter 7 it really
describes an experience of the early
advent believers in the early 1800s that
based on their study of the book of
daniel came to a conclusion that jesus
was coming at the end of the 2300 day
prophecy around 1844
they did the math correctly but they
misunderstood the event they thought the
sanctuary being cleansed was the earth
and so there was a mystery there there
was something that was not fully
understood and some have seen in the
seven thunder sort of a parallel of that
experience where something's revealed
but it's not completely understood until
the event passes
so maybe there'll be a clear
understanding of this as certain events
begin to take place as we near the end
yeah and jesus said to the disciples he
said there's many things i have to say
to you now but you're not able to bear
them so there was truth and he said it's
too soon for me to tell you this right
and things were revealed as they were
able to handle it you know you might
enjoy our free offer tonight uh glenn
it's on the books of daniel and
revelation and it's a one of our
magazines if you'd like to receive that
just call 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the daniel and
revelation magazine we'll be happy to
send it to you we've got anthony
listening in new york anthony you're on
bible answers live yes good evening
pastors um
my uh question i have two bible verses
for the for my question uh the first one
is revelation four verse eight um
it says and the four beasts had each of
them
uh six wings about him and they were
full of eyes within
and this is the part
i hone in on and they rest not day and
night saying
holy holy holy lord god almighty which
was and is and is to come and then i
look in revelation chapter eight verse
one
and at the opening of the seventh seal
it says and when he had opened the
seventh seal
there was silence in heaven about the
space of half an hour
so i was just wondering
how that works together is there
something
that causes those angels to pause from
saying holy holy holy day and night for
that space of half an hour and then even
what is that half an hour in heavenly
time yeah well there's an exception here
obviously
when
there's silence in heaven
that would lead us to believe that
heaven is vacated now when will heaven
be vacated what says when christ comes
all the holy angels come with him
so if all of the angels have come with
christ and christ is coming in the glory
of the father
then this reveals that time period now
in bible prophecy
a day is a year
and so some have wondered well if it's
talking about silence in heaven for the
space about half an hour
one hour
is you know 1 24th of a day
which would be 15 days about half of 15
is 7.
so it's telling us that there's like a
seven day period when
the
heavenly staff
they come to
a redeemer jesus sends us angels to
gather together as elect and we're
caught up to meet him in the air and
there's this procession he may take us
on a tour through the galaxies
uh on our way to heaven we're not sure
but that's why i think there's silence
in heaven
all the focus of the universe really at
the time is what's happening with christ
coming at the second coming with all the
angels and so that's the emphasis but i
think for the most part pastor the
reference in revelation chapter four
that talks about these these four living
creatures saying holy holy holy that is
the case as god does something or
reveals his glory or
acts in history the response of the
angels is holy holy holy in the presence
of god so yes that's forever and ever
that's general terms but yeah there's a
little exception here and that's that
silence in heaven about a half an hour
yeah you also find in isaiah chapter 6
so seraphim around the throne of god are
saying holy holy holy
so i think revelation is borrowing from
or referring back to isaiah's experience
hey thank you anthony good question
all right we have harold listening in
illinois harold welcome to the program
all right thanks for taking my call yeah
so uh what kind of led me to christ to
some extent was understanding john where
he says before abraham was i am
i'm trying to understand
the interaction between jesus and the
jews
when he says your father when jesus says
to the jews your father abraham rejoiced
that he would see my day
he saw it and was glad this is in john 8
what is he referring to he would see my
day
well
god revealed many things to abraham
abraham was called a prophet
and i think that abraham saw the day of
christ in other words the coming of
christ is our sacrifice
most clearly
when he had the experience of offering
his son on the mountains of moriah
and god said you know
don't don't bring the knife down don't
sacrifice your son this was a test and
it was also a living demonstration
in that you are willing to offer your
son uh i'm gonna be offering my son see
what abraham said to isaac when isaac
said where's the lamb he said we got the
wood we got the fire where's the lamb
and abraham said my son god will provide
himself a sacrifice
abraham saw the messiah's coming i think
it was revealed to him that god would
send his son so i think jesus is
referring to that abraham was looking
forward to that promised son of which
isaac was a type that would save the
world from sin
and you know we do have a book that
talks about this great cost of the cross
and that's what it's called the cost of
the cross that talks about christ and
his sacrifice and how even in the old
testament it was revealed in shadows and
types through the sacrifice sacrifice
and through the sanctuary service we'll
be happy to make that available to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800 835
that is a free offer line you can ask
for the book it's called the high cost
of the cross we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks well thank
you harold we've got lindsay listening
from also
idaho lindsay welcome to the program
hi thank you for taking the call
um my question is i am wondering what
does the bible say about
praying for others more so that are
unbelievers
well there's no question the bible tells
us to pray and intercede for others
and the ones who would need it most
would be the ones who they're weak in
faith or they don't have faith
moses went up the mountain to intercede
for god's people even after they had you
know gone into paganism and worshiped a
golden calf so you know they would
qualify as people in a lost condition
there it says that they uh
they had a party and
they were unclothed
so it turned into kind of a debauched
orgy or something after uh the golden
calf experience
so moses went up and he interceded for
him and god heard his prayer and he gave
the people another chance and showed
them mercy you see many times when moses
interceded for the people abraham
interceded for a lot
and for the he actually
interceded for the people of sodom and
gomorrah as well in praying for a lot
and one time god heard abraham and lot
was and sodom and gomorrah were spared
when he rescued them from the assyrians
that had invaded from the north
and
then you go through the new testament
and you know
bible talks about many examples of
prayer and intercession
you know it's almost like in one sense
the bible reveals to us a great
controversy between the forces of good
and the forces of evil and it seems that
intercessory prayer
allows god to do more to try and
influence a person
than he would do if we didn't pray
and you know i kind of imagine that if
god of course god wants to save as many
people as he he possibly can
but there are certain rules you might
say in this great controversy there are
things that god won't allow the devil to
do and god being a god of justice
restricts his influence to some degree
but when somebody intercedes on behalf
of somebody else it almost gives god the
right to say let me do more because this
person is praying specifically for that
individual that doesn't mean that they
don't have free will of course people
can still choose
but that's why we find intercessory
prayers so prominent in the bible jesus
prayed for his disciples disciples
prayed for others
christians throughout christian history
have prayed and interceded for others so
there's great value in intercessory
prayer how many parents have prayed for
their children and i know pastor we've
seen examples of a godly mother who has
prayed for a wayward son and she might
even
pass away and after her death her son
comes to accept christ she doesn't see
the fruit of her prayers at least in
this life but there's power intercessory
prayer absolutely
we have a book it's called teach us to
pray and we'll make happy to send this
to anyone who asks the number is
800-835-6747 and again you can ask for
the book it's called teach us to pray
danny's listening in arizona danny
welcome to the program so my question
comes from matthew 14 uh 29 when jesus
walks on water um
so
peter comes off and he also walks in
water jesus tells him to come and so
he's actually walking so i'm i imagine
that his faith is actually allowing him
to do that
but
um when he starts to think
was it his lack of faith and
uh or was it also his focus that um
drove them down to the to the to the
water you know i think that you're on
target with both i think that he changed
his focus it says that he was looking at
christ and walking on the water but then
he saw the wind and the waves were
boisterous in other words he took his
eyes off of christ when his focus
changed
his faith changed which is just a very
very important point for
every believer that if we take our eyes
off the solution and focus on the
problem we can become discouraged
the reason that david was able to defeat
goliath
is you know he said you come you've got
a sword and a spear and a shield he had
his helmet in his armor david said but
i'm coming against you in the name of
the lord david's focus was on the answer
which is the lord not on the problem
which was the giant
and so i think that's key to the
christian life don't take your eyes off
the answer and just focus on the problem
or you'll start thinking
it's like those 10 spies that went to
look at the promised land and all they
saw was the problems
but joshua and caleb they saw the
solution and they made it to the
promised land because they had faith and
they had the right focus
and the focus okay all right yeah that
was my question i was like is is faith
really that fragile
can can it be that fragile in a person
yeah i think i think it's um
your faith is directly impacted by
where you direct your attention
to the strength of the lord trusting the
lord you start looking at your weakness
and your problems
and it can happen that quickly i believe
it
all right well thank you danny for your
call we got joey listening in michigan
jerry welcome to the program
oh hello hi yeah this is joey coming
from michigan we we listened to you on
strong tower radio we were just asked
from their christmas party so oh good
good
yeah uh anyway i have a question we were
um reading
kings this is my first time through the
bible and in second kings they talk
about jeroboam a lot about being like
kind of like the cookie cutter for the
evil guy or whatever they are to
somebody um
that's in the way of jeroboam is evil
i just wonder why they always
go back to him and is there more than
one jeroboam
yes yes
there is more than one jeroboam
and i think there's another king that
named his son jeroboam
um
but
the jeroboam that is the most infamous
when the kingdom of israel broke away
from the kingdom of
judah the ten tribes in the north broke
away they picked a new king instead of
the sons of david they said we're gonna
pick our own king and jeroboam is the
one who instigated that that rebellion
and
you know i all would have been well
except he said you know i'm afraid now
that the people in my kingdom are going
to go to the temple in judah
which was
a rehoboam's kingdom the son of solomon
and he said i'm afraid they're going to
start going down there and their hearts
are going to be drawn back to judah
and they'll lose their loyalty so to
prevent them from needing to go to
jerusalem for the feasts
he said we're going to set up altars in
bethel and dan and he made golden calves
which god had clearly told them not to
do they'd already got in trouble doing
that once before
and he began to make people priests that
were not of the levites or the sons of
aaron
and the bible was very clear that only
the levites and the sons of aaron were
to serve in the temple and as priests
and he basically led the kingdom those
ten tribes into idolatry which is
breaking one of the commandments
so from then on
the bible talks about jeroboam the son
of nebat who did make israel to sin he
led the whole nation away and it lasted
i guess all the way through the time of
ahab until they fell
so there was i believe another
king who named his son jeroboam
and there may even be just you know
someone in the chronologies named
jeroboam that isn't related it wasn't
that
uncommon of a name
but um yeah that one infamous king he
was a servant of assad
broke away
of idolatry exactly yeah he set the
stage and it just lasted for generations
okay
so if you look up the phrase jeroboam
who caused israel to sin i think that's
about 15 times in the old testament okay
very good well thank you so much thank
you all right i appreciate your question
joey
all right we've got smyrna listening
from california smyrna welcome to the
program
hi good evening pastor ross pastor doug
batchelor it's it's beautiful to talk to
you this evening
and i have a very special question who
came out actually from my 13 year old
he had asked me
what happened to lazarus after he was
resurrected since we know that he was
the best friend of jesus
so the question is what happened to him
after he was
resurrected did he go to heaven after
jesus died
and um he got resurrected and then you
know he was couple days in earth um with
his disciples but then
he you know he he he went to heaven we
know that
so his question is if lazarus went with
him to heaven
all right good question now there are
several people that jesus and the
apostles and a couple of old testament
prophets resurrected
elijah and elisha both resurrected boys
that were dead in the old testament
they grew up and they lived normal lives
and then they died again
but they were saved from a premature
death
in the new testament jesus resurrected
oh is it three people
he resurrected the widow son of nain he
resurrected the daughter jarius and he
resurrected lazarus and then he
resurrected himself he said i lay my
life down i take it up again
um but the three people that he
resurrected they lived normal lives and
then they died again either from
sickness or accident or
or sabotage
you know the the bible tells us that the
religious leaders were so uncomfortable
that lazarus was a living testimony of
jesus power they even wanted to kill him
but there's no record that they did kill
him they were just threatened by him but
as far as we know lazarus did not go to
heaven
and you might be thinking of the parable
of the rich man and lazarus and lazarus
was a very common name like you know the
name john president company included
uh you know or tom or bob they're just
very common name and so there's it's not
unusual that jesus used the word lazarus
in his parable
now there is a group that was
resurrected at the time of christ's
resurrection that you know wasn't dead
then no he wasn't so you don't think
he's part of the group right right no
not at all but it does talk about this
group that will resurrect the time of
christ's resurrection and it seems as
though they were taken to heaven at the
ascension of christ but as pastor doug
points out lazarus was alive and well at
that time
and probably was still involved in
helping to provide for his sisters at
home so we have no record of him going
to heaven although you know most likely
he's waiting for the resurrection just
like the other saints the other
believers are waiting for the second
coming of christ in the resurrection
yeah we have a study that talks about
the resurrection death and the
resurrection and we'd be happy to send a
free copy of that too yeah absolutely
it is talking about the second coming of
christ and what happens when jesus comes
it's called rescue from above and uh
tells you all about the second coming
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who asks for it it's just 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide
rescue from above and we'll be happy to
send it right out all right we got 47
seconds until our break i don't think
that'd be fair to take a question right
now pastor ross and let's just remind
people that if you are not acquainted
with amazing facts
if you simply go to that website
amazingfacts.com or dot o r g
you're gonna find out that there is a
tree of life and it's got all these
different branches we've got media we
have radio programs you can listen to
archives of bible answers live you can
go to the amazing facts youtube channel
and there are probably hundreds of
videos on by different bible studies at
the youtube channel so we invite you to
start exploring all of the amazing fact
resources both video audio and written
many are free and there's also some
premium things you can buy we'll be back
in just a moment to take more bible
questions
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
written by the hand of god
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
[Music]
get pastor doug batchelor's 12-part
sermon series on the 10 commandments by
calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened
why did god create a day of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship
who is behind this great shift discover
the truth behind god's law and how it
was changed visit sabbathtruth.com
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown
these are the images people generally
associate with the tribulation and the
day of the lord but did you know the
bible speaks about another day of the
lord just before the great judgment day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being
a day the entire world is largely
forgotten
you'll be surprised to learn how this
special day of the lord factors into
last day prophecies such as the mark of
the beast the seal of god and the great
final tribulation
it's all contained in this new
eye-opening dvd series called the last
day of prophecy to order call
800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible-related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 p.m
and 8 p.m pacific time to receive any of
the bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and if you have a bible
question that's why we're here if you've
joined us along the way this is a live
international interactive bible study
you can call in your questions by
dialing 800
god says that's
800-463-7297 that'll bring you into the
studio we're also streaming this program
on
facebook and you can watch it on the
amazing facts facebook page or the doug
batchelor facebook page and the amazing
facts tv channel which is on satellite
around the country as well as you can go
to roku and watch amazing facts
television or on the internet af tv.org
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross and we've got a whole group of
people who are waiting to give us their
bible questions so we're going to go to
gabriella and
from south carolina gabriela welcome to
the program
so my question is i know the bible in
first timothy 2 9 says
that women shouldn't adorn themselves
with girl or gold or um
pearls
so
what about like gemstones do those count
as jewelry too
well you know the principle is and i
want to make clear there's going to be
plenty of people in heaven that word
jewelry
but when you study in the bible the
bible seems to encourage that we avoid
ornamentation on our bodies
when the children of israel made the
golden calf they made it from their
earrings and their their jewels and
then afterward god said break off your
ornaments now ornament it's not just
going to be gold or pearls it could be
silver it could be crystals it could be
you know anything
so the thing is
you know
as soon as you begin to open the door
and what i'm sharing here some people
are shocked in our culture because
there's whole stores that are called
christian jewelry
but i think as soon as you open the door
for christians to start wearing
all kinds of different baubles and beads
that people some people are insecure
about their appearance and they try to
compensate by hanging more valuables on
themselves and maybe increase their
perceived self-worth and
and you know some people maybe take it
too far
and so i just think it's better for
christians not to wear jewelry
and
i know that when the judgment comes and
god is not going to stop me at the
pearly gates and say doug i can't let
you in why not lord you didn't wear
enough jewelry
you know so i just try not to create a
stumbling block the bible speaks against
jacob and his family they buried their
jewelry when they went to meet with the
lord and
and
isaiah chapter 3 talks about the proud
daughters of zion and then it begins to
enumerate their articles of jewelry that
they they wear
so and what i'm saying like i said this
is not just me this is what you used to
hear from pentecostals baptist
methodists they all used to talk about
john wesley wrote widely about it
said well christians need to be careful
about their attire not just golden
jewelry it's not about modesty and in
our culture today
men and women they often dress in a very
provocative way and
bible's clear that we should be modest
in our apparel you know we do have a
book that deals with a jewelry it's
called jewelry how much is too much this
is a common question that we get passed
today so we have some bible resources on
that if you'd like to learn more about
the subject call
how 800-835-6747 is too much you know
pastor talking about jewelry we know of
some fairly well-known uh
tele-evangelists
who were on tv and
one of the criticisms that came against
these televangelists was just the amount
of jewelry that they were both them and
their wives but very expensive necklaces
and bracelets and
rings just about on every finger it just
doesn't set the right especially when
they're begging for us i know
it doesn't set the right tone you can't
imagine and then you see what would
jesus do exactly that's the thing is
what would jesus do yeah so all right
well thanks for your call we've got uh
nuke listening from minnesota nuke
welcome to the program
all right so i just had one question so
my question was really um based off of a
principle in the bible in isaiah chapter
28 verses 9 and 10
where the bible says that the lord
declared the end from the beginning
and or rather where he said precept upon
precept line upon line here a little and
there a little and then where he says in
isaiah 46 verses 9 and 10 that he
declared the end from the beginning
and so
when i
look at the beginning you know when i
look at genesis
i see that you know there's
there's the beast
you know which is the serpent
there's the woman and then there's adam
who was at the time he was the king of
the earth before he sinned
and then we look in revelation
and we see the same thing we see the
beast we see the harlot woman and then
we see the kings of the earth that
committed fornication
with the harlot woman
and so the reason that i emphasize this
is because i wanted to see um why is it
that
we believe
that in revelation
the harlot woman and the beast they're
the same entity
when in genesis
which is the beginning
we don't see them to be the same
entities we see that the beast and the
woman are two totally separate um
two totally separate entities
okay
now i hope i understood your question
because you went you know from isaiah
about
god declaring the end from the beginning
to revelation of the beasts
um but let me focus on the last thing
you said uh how do we know that the
beast and the woman are the same
in revelation you see an evolution of
the beast
so the the dragon that you see with
seven heads and ten horns in revelation
chapter 12
is that same roman power but it goes
through a change by the time you get to
revelation 17 where you now see a woman
riding on that beast so there's a
confederacy between this woman and the
beast
and
you know
most uh protestant theologians believe
that the woman in revelation 17 was
talking about how the church had
commingled christian teachings with
roman pagan teachings and that's why
it's pictured as a woman there so you
see there's sort of a consolidation of
rome pagan rome with christianity which
was supposed to be christ's bride but
she's become unfaithful and should
become a political power
she's now committing fornication with
the kings of the earth
and
so you know you see and then you've got
the different beasts in daniel in
revelation so you've got a lot of beasts
that are evolving through the bible
culminating with the final persecuting
power
well i think to be consistent with bible
symbolism a beast represents a political
power and a woman represents a church
what's unique about revelation chapter
17 you have a woman and a beast
so the power that's described in
revelation 7 or revelation 17 is not
only a religious power symbolized by the
woman but it is also a political power
and if you look at what this power
represents we understand that to be
the papal power
the church of rome not only is it
clearly a religious power it's the
largest church in the world the largest
christian church but it is also an
independent nation the smallest country
in the world is the vatican 109 acre
country that's right so it's a political
power and a religion and they do have a
wall around it they do have a wall
around it they do
and they have ambassadors all over the
place they have an ambassador to the
united
about the states necessarily we're still
faithful to the symbols we're not
talking about the same it is the same
power but it's different aspects of the
same power it's the religious power
represented by the woman the political
power represented by the beast
so hopefully that made some sense nick
did we answer your question
yeah i can see i can see what you guys
are saying with the political power and
the religious power looking at it from
uh genesis is kind of what the the point
that i was making was that you know you
had the beast who
you got the serpent and the woman there
in genesis
yeah exactly and so the serpent enticed
the woman into taking of that fruit that
would have been a representation of his
power and then she enticed the king of
the earth to partake of it and with her
enticing the king of the earth
with her enticing the king of the earth
what that did was that allowed the whole
world to fall into corruption this very
same way we see in revelation the beast
entice the woman and the woman she
corrupts the earth with her false
teachings and ideologies yeah you know
so that was the really that was the uh
parallel that i was trying to make to
see if you guys could see that well
there's actually you've got a good point
there and we have a book that talks
about the beast the dragon and the woman
that makes some of the same parallels
yeah absolutely
i really enjoy it if you'd like to
receive that book just call
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
the dragon the beast and the woman we'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
and asks it's a fascinating study
revelation 17. thanks for your call nuke
we've got janet listening in north
carolina jana welcome to the program
good evening pastors and thank you and
bless you both for your ministry and
taking the time to do this and i just
have to say pastor doug i seven years
ago i watched a little online thing you
did about the sabbath and you changed
and saved my life so oh praise the lord
i can't thank you enough praise the lord
thank you so much for that janet and
thank you enough for that well that's
why we do it
i've been doing your bible reading plan
and we we just finished up reading
daniel and at the very end of daniel 12
verses 11 to 13 it talks about two other
time prophecies that i mean i i learned
about all the other ones from all your
present truth the 1260 days the 2300
days the 70 weeks but i never heard
anyone talk about these two other time
prophecies and i was just wondering what
they were about
you know the the these
you've got more time prophecies in
daniel chapter 12 than any other chapter
in the bible it mentions a 1260-day
period a 1290 day period and a 1335 day
period
and you know rather than
you almost have to draw a chart for
someone on the screen and explain
uh what this is talking about but most
of the prophecies in daniel are talking
about the persecution that god's people
would go through during this time this
great persecution of the dark ages
jesus refers to this great time of
trouble
and it the heart of it is this 1260 year
period
which is what you'd call three and a
half
prophetic years
1260 days
that's three and a half jewish
years
they had 30 days in a month the
revelation calls it 42 months
and it also talks about the time periods
that led into that with the 1335 and the
1290. you know my best thing is if she
got that magazine on daniel in
revelation i think there's a chart in
there that explains that it is it'll
make it it's hard to make that in three
minutes or so
yeah if you're looking for just a
starting point just real quick for those
dates the 1290 begins in 508 and the
point the reason that's specifically
mentioned is the conversion of clovis
king of the franks and france became the
greatest supporter of the paper roman
empire right
so that's why that date is specifically
mentioned 1290 will bring you up to 1798
when the papal power was broken
and the pope was taking a prisoner and
they confiscated the political states of
the vatican at the time the 1335 brings
you right up to 1843 which is a
significant date as it relates to the
2300 days
grateful for awakening that's right
again that's all in the magazine daniel
in revelation we'll be happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks the
number for that is 800-835-6747
and ask for the daniel and revelation
magazine and as we said a little earlier
this is not something that we can offer
every week but we're doing it this week
so take advantage of it and you'll be
blessed
next quarter that we have is elijah
elijah listening from washington elijah
welcome to the program
i got a couple quick questions here um
the first is
about the ark of the covenant we just
did a um
a bible amazing prophecy here in a
seminar with mark fox and yakima here
but my question is
um
is the we know the ark of the covenant
is in heaven and the sanctuary is being
cleansed and but i was wondering i've
heard somewhere where maybe
the ark might be found like the actual
ark of the covenant here on earth that
might be discovered
all right now in revelation and pastor
ross i think it's in revelation 16 where
it says i saw heaven open in the ark of
the covenant
revelation 11 11 sorry okay in
revelation 11 it does mention the ark
being seen in heaven i don't think that
means that god caught the ark that had
been captured or that had been
hidden by jeremiah the prophet um i
don't think that means that that was
caught up to heaven i think it's also
talks about the altar of incense in
heaven
yeah that's all there so those are
symbols of the sanctuary it's taking us
through i believe the real ark of the
covenant is still on earth and it's
probably hidden somewhere in the
vicinity of jerusalem
because before nebuchadnezzar destroyed
the temple and jeremiah the prophet
clearly forewarned king zedekiah he said
the temple is going to be burned with
fire
and they wanted to preserve their
national treasure and jeremiah with some
of the priests very likely hid it
in one of the many caves that honey
combed the city of jerusalem
and um
before so the babylonians were not
captured it's never mentioned from that
time onward it's probably still hidden
most of the people who probably knew the
secret died except jeremiah and of
course he's dead now too
so
will it be revealed again before the end
of time that'd be a wonderful
archaeological it'd be the greatest
archaeological that's right fine
we thought uh the discovery of king
tutankhamun's tomb was of significance
could you just imagine the discovery of
the ark of the covenant that would be
spectacular it'd be a lot easier to
preach the ten commandments if that
that's right
all right well thanks for calling elijah
uh next quarter that we have is uh jota
listening from pittsburgh hey jota
welcome to the program
listen my question is based uh we're
going to go back into genesis the sixth
chapter
now back when i was in oakland college
with uh elder cleveland and dr wright
these people that i knew so well
i we there was one
uh section of genesis 6 i've always
had a question about
and it deals with the idea of what
went into the ark of noah
now we're told that uh of the two
unclean and seven pairs with seven with
the clean
are were supposed to go inside of the
ark and the bible says there
is to me is specific it says of what i
made
and my point would almost be phrased
like this
why is it there jurassic park in the ark
i believe
that dinosaurs and all these types of
creatures
that were outside of the ark were not
creatures that god made
and i'm curious if if that uh line of
reasoning would sound like something
that could be considered i i think that
carbon dating it might be inaccurate i
don't believe that there
are uh creatures that were here 30
million years before
uh god said let there be light
so how do we
uh uh make the appearance of these
things fit
the narrative of what actually what is
the ark okay well uh first of all um
the bible tells us that god told noah to
you know uh create the the ark so that
it could preserve all life
and some people they see the giant
dinosaur bones i lived across the street
from
literally across the street from the
american museum of natural history as a
kid in new york city and i would go look
at the great
the bone assemblies of the triceratops
and the tyrannosaurus rex and the
brontosaurus and these huge reptiles
thunder lizards that's the dinosaur
and people say how in the world are you
going to fit two of those on the ark
well i
i i know that there are reptiles that
were preserved by god on the ark and
they believed that these were just big
reptiles
so which ones may have been amalgamated
by man that were not preserved and which
ones were reptiles that god created that
just were large i mean alligators
you know they they find uh fossils of
alligators that were 50 feet long
well maybe that's an exaggeration a lot
bigger right now they got them over 20
feet they had some yeah they may be 50
feet long huge alligator-like creatures
and so but no one didn't have to
necessarily take the full grown ones he
could have taken eggs for that matter i
mean i don't know that he did that but
he could take in very small ones
and
i think the moody bible research did a
study and they said that you know the
average animal in the world today is the
size of a sheep or smaller and god
didn't need to take 20 different kinds
of dog he took two
probably wolf-like dogs and all the
other dog breeds have come from them
just like all the different races of
people in the world came from adam and
eve
so
um
i believe that you know there were
reptiles on the ark there were a lot of
very big ones a lot of big mammals too
that lived before the flood
and it seems the whole environment and
everything became dwarfed and stunted
after the flood
which ones may have been the
amalgamation of man that didn't get on
the ark i don't know it doesn't say in
in the bible or anywhere else well you
know we also do have in i'm thinking of
the book of job it talks about a
behemoth yeah leviathan that lives in
the sea and then a behemoth and it says
god made them so god made leviathan god
made behemoth and if you look at the
description that we find there in the
book of job it's not a description of
any animal that we have now
it talks about its tail being as thick
as the cedar and its legs being big and
round so it can't be an elephant because
an elephant has a tiny little tail but
it's a description of some kind of it
could very well be some kind of a
dinosaur that lived it talks about how
that had lived by the reeds and by the
water and that's very interesting
description but as you mentioned pastor
the environment changed you have wooly
mammoths that
must have made it on the ark because
they survived after the flood they died
out eventually so we don't know which of
those those giant animals actually uh
made it through the nimrod in the bible
is called the mighty hunter and he
probably they were some of these big
things down you're not a mighty hunter
for killing a mouse right you're a
mighty hunter because you're killing
something big right and they may have
rendered some of these survivors extinct
so it'll be interesting to go back and
see
how that played out you know we do have
a book that talks about you know it was
mentioned in the call carbon dating
we have a book called how science flunk
no how evolution flunk the science test
and it talks about some of these
commonly uh believed or accepted
theories
that if you look at a little bit deeper
you realize it's not built in a very
solid foundation the book is called how
evolution flunk the science test and
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls an ass the number is
800-835-6747
and we'll get that in the mail and send
it out to you we've got chase listening
in illinois chase welcome to the program
yeah i have a question it's about isaiah
65 verse 20 where it says no more shall
an infant from there live but a few days
nor old man who has not fulfilled his
days for the child shall die 100 years
old but the sinner being 100 years old
shall be accursed
um i was wondering because i remembered
you talked about this before in one of
your sermons how it's like the child it
doesn't mean that the child like dies in
heaven because there's no one dying in
heaven but it's saying that they'll
mature after 100 years of age and i was
just wondering like is that concept also
kind of illustrated in genesis chapter 5
when it talks about the genealogy of
adam
yeah you'll notice that in the early
genealogies that some of these people
were not even getting married and having
children until they were over a hundred
now that was amazing by the time of
abraham because
you know then they had a more normal
lifespan but
um
people matured more slowly they live
longer
and
in heaven kids will not grow into
maturity in you know 15 years i think
that they're going to parents are going
to get to enjoy them being children a
little longer if they're reunited in the
resurrection and they're still children
they'll get to grow up bible talks about
children in heaven that
you know a child will lead the wolf and
the lion and the lamb child plays on the
whole of a venomous serpent and it
doesn't hurt
so yeah but they'll grow more slowly so
when it says a child will die a hundred
years old dies an unfortunate
translation there's no children dying in
heaven it's talking about child won't
even cease to be a child
and the word die and cease can sometimes
be interchanged there
pastor ross we have three minutes can we
do another question yes we've got wanda
listening in british columbia wanda
welcome to the program
so i have a question and it's in psalms
23 verse 4
and it says
yea though i walk through the valley the
shadow of death that will fear no evil
for thou art with me thy rod and thy
staff they comfort me
so i was wondering the difference
between the rod and the staff
the significance of them
and why they would comfort me
all right well that's a good question um
a shepherd would have a staff now they
could do one of two things a shepherd
might have two different sticks one is
like a club
that was more of a weapon against
jackals and things that might harm the
sheep another one was the staff some of
them used one
for both
and the staff often had a crook on the
end of it and if you needed to grab a
sheep it's hard to run up and catch them
but if they had a crook where they would
scoot it around their back leg and it
would capture their back leg and they
pull it up towards them and that would
sometimes be a means of discipline
but it would also be used to ward off
anything that might harm them and so we
are comforted by
god's uh protection
and by his discipline
and so david as a shepherd he employed
these symbols he was very well
acquainted with
that you know the shepherds rod and his
staff
are both for the benefit of the sheep
yeah okay well that's that makes sense
so the rod is more of a disciplining one
for
keeping in line well i think the staff
is the one that they use for hooking the
sheep and bringing it in and the rod was
the one that
they would use against the wolf or the
bear that comes to take you often hear
about the rod of aaron and moses that
was lifted up and there's you know
leading the sheep moses was a shepherd
and in revelation talks about jesus
coming with the rod of iron to execute
judgment upon the record well he's
coming as the good shepherd to protect
his sheep because in revelation there is
a death decree that's passed just before
jesus comes so christ comes to the
rescue of his people and yeah it is a
judgment that falls upon the wicked so
the rod protects us the staff guides us
and we can see both of those parallels
or symbols being used in the bible very
good good question all right well i'm
looking at the clock pass today we got a
minute before we gonna
say goodbye to our friends who are
listening on satellite radio for the
rest of you are listening we do have our
bonus questions and we like this part of
the program we try to answer as many
bible questions in about two minutes and
we get those questions sent to us so if
you have a question that you'd like to
try and have us answer you can just send
your question to bal questions at
amazingfacts.org that's the website bl
questions at amazingfacts.org and as i
said we take about two minutes past the
doug and try to answer as many questions
possible we've got a whole bunch of
questions so we're we're looking forward
to that segment of the program so for
those of you who are listening on
satellite radio
we're going to have to say goodbye to
you in just a few seconds but please go
ahead and take a look at the amazing
facts website we mentioned the address
earlier just amazingfacts.com.org
you can find archived programs of bible
answers live as well as a lot of
additional and fantastic resources so
hopefully god willing will be able to
visit again next week on another edition
of bible answers live
amen
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
well pastor doug we've got a number of
questions that's come in and we want to
greet those who stayed by for this part
of the program so here we go question
number one
pastor doug do you have any idea how
long adam and eve lived in the garden
before they sinned
well we don't know the exact time but
chances are it was not very long because
god told them be fruitful and multiply
presumably the plumbing was working
perfectly they had not had any children
yet so i'm guessing that they'd probably
only been there a matter of months
before
they fell into sin
all right next question that we have is
there a difference biblically speaking
between a messenger and a prophet
um
well you know someone could be as you
mentioned before a career prophet where
it's a calling upon their life and then
other times god might be giving a person
a particular message for a specific time
in person and so in that sense yes there
could be a difference
okay question number three what will
happen to those who are living but they
are not saved when jesus comes the
second time
it says the wicked if they're unsaved
they're in the category of the lost they
are destroyed by the brightness of his
coming revelation says they're calling
for the rocks and the mountains to fall
on them and hide them from the face of
the one who sits on the throne
so for them it's not a good day
okay next question that we have luke 22
47 says but they who did not know but
committed things worthy of stripes shall
be beaten with few stripes and the
question is asked
is this justice
yeah you know
every judge will meet out sentence
based on knowledge if a person
committed a crime
in ignorance
then it's very different than a person
who read the law they knew the law they
saw the sign it's you know if you tell
the the officer look the speed limit
changed and you didn't have it posted i
did not know he's going to show you more
mercy than if you drove by six signs
that said speed limit 55 and you're
going 90.
so he said look you knew you saw it so
the lord judges us based upon knowledge
okay last quick question pastor dog
you've got the father the son and the
holy spirit and that is the godhead or
the trinity but are they all one being
or one person
three separate persons and part of the
reason we know this is you look at the
baptism of jesus and you see
god the father is in heaven he is
speaking jesus is not being a
ventriloquist he said this is my beloved
son and god the spirit is coming down in
the form of a dove and of course when
jesus prayed to the father and the
father answers and says you know i will
glorify you and i have glorified you
you've got individual persons
hey thank you listening friends it's
been so much fun answering your bible
questions god willing we'll have another
chance next week make sure and tune in
and check out the amazing facts website
[Music]
you